it's gonna be pretty and doing this all
the time not knowing this is gonna end
that will come back and we'll do it
again so embarrassing Maisie Williams
sophie Turner and kid Harrington
reacting to their early scenes on Game
of Thrones is probably my new favorite
thing oh my gosh
I am in medieval times I'm not in 2009
anymore I've never done anything like
this before
and if you thought that was precious
wait till you see a baby Jon Snow it's
my first ever filming of anything in
costume walking about with a massive
cloak and sword that's been the most fun
thing is just pretending to be in this
world we know Sophie and Maisie are BFFs
IRL and turns out it's been like that
since day one
me amazing best friends on set we met in
the auditions must believe the column
anymore
father censor we get on really well
their life I think we're gonna be
friends for a long time I need the
cutest Sophie Anne Joe Jonas are gearing
up for their second wedding in Paris and
Maisie should have a special part in the
ceremony she could be one of your
bridesmaids
that's just my maid of honor
amazing - they really are friendship
goals the most fun I had was working
with Sophie just my best friend I mean
like who else gets to go to work with
their best friend my favorite day on set
would be the day that I was reunited
with Maisie who can keep it together the
new clip is part of the game of Thrones
reunion special hosted by Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
[Music]
it'll be featured in the complete
collection blu-ray sets available just
in time for Christmas on December 3rd G
ot ended earlier this year and while
some fans were upset with the ending the
cast was just as emotional saying
goodbye to their beloved characters I
was just numb when I read like my last
page because it's just so sad it's so
sad that like that is the last time like
I'm reading my character you know and
it's just got to go on a long long walk
I it was just really emotional like I
feel like everything you do it's like
you can start to get yourself so down
being like this is the last I'm gonna
read script this is like the last time
I'm gonna be in this location and like
it got to a point where I had to just
stop doing that I was gonna just have
looking at with breakdown ah they kind
of break my heart I want to hear from
you guys though do you miss Game of
Thrones what do you love most about
Sophie and Maisie let me know and for
all the latest on your favorite celebs
keep it locked to all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for
now